he was probably about 15. and um
he comes down into my room
hey y'all
yeah you recognize that voice
my computer has a virus
will you come down and check it out as a
sure man
i'm walking over to his room with him i
go just out of curiosity
what websites are looking at because i
really feel like an honest answer
can kick us to the finish line of this
conversation you know what i mean
so but he's not ready to be honest with
me yet and so he
he thinks of whatever lie he thinks will
work and he goes you know
uh just the usual one cnn i'm like oh
really cnn
i said just out of curiosity what what
stories are you looking at there he goes
you know i like the ones about syria i'm
like
syria
i said it's pronounced syria and he goes
that's not how i say it
[Laughter]
so i go to his computer and look he's
either too stupid or lazy
to clear his brows but he did try to
fool me it's the first website
cnn and he went one deeper second
website
espn third website
come fiesta
and i go hey dude uh
what's the deal with this one right here
and i can tell he's gonna lie to me and
anybody follows me knows this
this is his mo this is how i can tell
he's gonna lie to me i could tell he's
gonna lie to me
because when i put it up the website he
bent over and he squinted like he didn't
know how to read all this stuff
just started shaking his head like an
[ __ ] for no reason
[Music]
he goes yeah i'm uh i've never seen
those two words before
he said why don't you try to pronounce
it for me he goes well i wouldn't even
know where to start
i said why don't you start with those
first three legs
then he goes back to the squint okay
[Laughter]
i'm doing this for you dad
oh no what does it say oh
[ __ ] fiesta what does that say
and i said pooh by esta i go you think
it's an academic website do you
magna [ __ ] fiesta is that what you think
it is
i said well i'm gonna click on it
because why i wouldn't do that
and i said why not this might be the
website that's causing all the problems
and he goes dad obviously i've been
hacked
and i said yeah man i don't know a lot
about computers but i don't think that's
how that works
and he goes no it is you're too old you
wouldn't understand
i said well i'm going to click on it
anyways he goes how are you really
and i said yeah and he goes hey
i'm gonna wait outside
i said no no we're gonna watch this
together
and he goes i really don't want to do
this
because nobody wants to watch porn with
their dad guys that's not a thing
but the fact that he was so
uncomfortable was making me kind of hard
i love that [ __ ] so much it's one of my
favorite things
so i click on it and i will tell you
what
that was a fiesta
looked like one person was getting all
the presents though
[Applause]
but i said to him i go to poor man and
he goes yeah
i'm sorry i lied i didn't want to
disappoint you
like a buddy not disappointing
age-appropriate you're 15.
age-appropriate for you to be curious
about sex yeah i'm not
you're not in trouble with me for
looking at porn but as your dad
there are some things i think it's
really important for you to know
as your father there are some things
they need to tell you thing number one
watching too much porn is bad watching
too much porn about you
especially a young man who's never had
sex before
if all he's doing is watching porn when
he gets his first girlfriend
[Laughter]
it's kind of set some pretty unrealistic
expectations for her
you know what i mean not every woman
likes a hairbrush in her [ __ ] that's
all i said
that's just for the porn i think you
know what i mean i told him you can try
that but you're going to come home sore
most of the time so
but then i said to michael i'm so
curious why you're watching why are you
watching
so much fun he goes well
i'm trying to learn some moves i said
are you watching porn
to learn how to have sex he's like yeah
i said that
is a terrible idea
and he goes why dad who else should i
watch
these are the professionals
it was not a terrible argument
but i i said okay okay well i'll take
that but but that's like watching lebron
james play basketball
thinking you can dunk that's not how it
works you're born with different skill
sets you know what i mean
think of big dicks you've got a nice
personality
[Music]
you're going to work with what the lord
gave you know now i know you're trying
to learn some moves but
[ __ ] somebody from 12 inches away is
not going to be one of your ways
so you're gonna have to get a little
more creative than that i think you know
[Applause]
you know when you have kids you can tell
when they're proud of themselves and he
didn't want to admit it
but i could tell he was proud of himself
so i said i go did you
did you learn something and he was like
now look this is when a normal parent
walks out of me because normal parents
do want they do not want to know what
their kid learned on comfiest
but normal parents don't need to find
new jokes for their act
it would be irresponsible of me to leave
i need to provide for the family
you know what i mean now it's at this
point in every story guys i'll
let you in a little secret it's at this
point in every story if i think i'm
gonna use something on stage
i will then try to manipulate my kids
into doing things that i think will be
fun
and so and by the way people ask all the
time how come there are more jokes about
your daughter it's a great question
it's at this point in every story when i
do try to manipulate them well she'll
look at me and she'll say
you're not getting a joke out of this
get out of here every
every [ __ ] time
why are all my jokes about my youngest
son
he's the dumbest one
he's a giver i don't know what to tell
you you know
so i i decide what i'll do is i'll just
start lobbing things up to see what
he'll do
so when he said he learned something
instead of walking out i just started
trying stuff
yeah he said he said he learned
something i said you did he goes yup
i said okay
show me
[Music]
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean you go show me show me on
the bed show me the moves you learn
[Laughter]
what like me and you no the [ __ ]
being here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i don't understand what you're saying to
me right now
i know buddy like look you play
basketball you go to the gym you
practice your free throws and nobody's
there right
yeah you work on your left when nobody's
there yeah it's muscle memory
it's the same with every physical
activity your muscles need to have
memory so when the game time happens you
just react
and you don't gotta think about it and
he goes i don't understand i go
jacob please tell me you've been in here
practice
and he goes
are you for
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah real look dude i go yeah i go when
your mom leaves every morning the door's
shut to my room what do you think i'm
doing
he goes you still practice i'm like yeah
how old were you when you started i said
well i was 14. he goes but i'm 15. i
said i know
and he said you tell me what to do dad
you you tell me what to do and i will do
it
and i said okay i said listen buddy
whatever moves you learned on the porn
you on top her on top you from behind
whatever it is you want to do
you need to be in here in your room on
your bed
every day
for 15 minutes a day
and he's such a sweet kid he goes
i will dad i won't let you down
[Applause]
and i'm ready to walk out of the room
guys just knowing
that he's gonna be in his room every day
15 minutes a day [ __ ] a ghost
fills me up in ways you all can't
possibly imagine
it makes me so happy that dude doesn't
need to be buy me a birthday present for
the rest of my life we're good right
and i'm walking out of the room but what
did i tell you he's a giver
so i get i'm almost at the door and i
hear him go well do you want me to just
show you right now yes i do
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and i walk back in and i'm not gonna lie
to you this
is when things got a little weird
because when i walk back into the room
he starts to slowly
walk over to his bed like this
eyeballing me the whole world
with this crazy confidence i'm like what
the [ __ ]
i'm leaning against the wall like
am i about to learn something
[Applause]
yo because when you've been married as
long as i have you try something new in
bed
your wife's gonna be like where'd you
learn that and what am i gonna say
[ __ ] jacob
[Applause]
that's not gonna go over that way
pay attention
[Music]
you might see something you've never
seen before
and i said well i am 100 sure of that
i'm positive i'm about to see something
i've never seen before
guys he good on that match he must have
humped that thing
killed like he was mad at it you know
what i mean
like it owed him money or something he
must have helped that mattress
190 times in six seconds
nobody's looking for a remodel bro
one it's one of my favorites two i love
seeing people's faces
who are upset for my son
[Laughter]
i want to just let all of you know
my family is the most important thing in
the world i would not tell stories
if it humiliated him or bothered him he
loves the attention he he said last week
well i'm not getting as many instagram
followers anymore
i go yeah i haven't put anything new out
on youtube why i need to start doing
some more stupid [ __ ]
so unclench your [ __ ] for him
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
you